Mes rendez-vous médicaux seraient planifiés sur les heures de travail,
et j'aurais une période de convalescence après les interventions chirurgicales.
Encore une fois, en tant qu'avocate,
j'avais analysé tout ce qui m'attendait pendant le traitement.
J'avoue, la majeure partie a été trouvée sur Google
sans doute pas ma meilleure idée, je ne le recommande pas.
(Rires)
Mais alors que j'étais prête pour les effets secondaires physiques,
ce qui m'effrayait le plus était le brouillard cérébral,
qui se définit par des pertes de mémoire,
des difficultés à se concentrer
et une incapacité à résoudre des problèmes.
Et si ça devait m'arriver,
comment pourrais-je exercer mon métier d'avocate ?
Devrais-je arrêter de travailler ?
Et comment avoir une discussion avec mon responsable
sur les arrangements dont j'avais besoin
sans savoir quel effet le traitement aurait sur moi ?
J'ai eu la chance d'avoir un responsable bienveillant et à l'écoute
qui a accepté de prendre les choses comme elles venaient,
plutôt que d'établir un plan précis dès le départ.
J'ai eu la chance que, sans avoir jamais entendu parler
de cette notion d'ajustements professionnels,
pour lui, ça relevait juste du bon sens.
Mais j'ai appris que ce n'était pas le cas pour tout le monde.
Qui suit un traitement découvrira comment ça l'affecte,
quelles sont ses limites
et apprendra à s'adapter en fonction.
J'ai appris quelques astuces par rapport au traitement lui-même
comme, avant d'aller en chimio,
faire attention à bien s'hydrater
et à avoir assez chaud, car ça aide l'infirmière à trouver vos veines.
Ne pas manger votre plat favori
avant, ou après la chimio,
car vous allez le vomir
et en être dégoûté à vie.
(Rires)
Je l'ai appris à mes dépens.
J'avais quelques trucs pour gérer au travail.
Je planifiais ma chimio très tôt, le lundi matin,
car je savais que dès que je quittais le service d'oncologie,
j'avais environ 4 heures de répit avant d'avoir l'esprit embrouillé
et de commencer à avoir la nausée.
Donc j'utilisais ce temps pour traiter mes mails et passer les appels urgents.
En 48 heures, le pire était passé
et je me remettais au travail de chez moi.
Le traitement a continué, mais je pouvais anticiper.
J'étais capable de prévoir avec mes collaborateurs
ce que je pouvais exécuter
et en combien de temps.
Mais j'entends encore l'hésitation dans leur voix
quand ils avaient une tâche à me confier.
En particulier celles avec des échéances.
Et croyez-moi, c'étaient des personnes
qui n'avaient pas peur de fixer des délais !
(Rires)
Je sentais qu'ils ne voulaient pas me mettre la pression
pendant mon traitement.
Et si j'appréciais l'intention,
j'avais néanmoins besoin de ces délais imposés.
Car c'était quelque chose que je pouvais maîtriser
et garder sous contrôle,
contrairement à tant d'autres choses.
Et pendant que je travaillais de chez moi,
je réfléchissais à comment les employeurs devraient appliquer ce concept
d'ajustements professionnels, à l'époque actuelle
quand un Australien sur deux
sera diagnostiqué d'un cancer avant 85 ans.
Et comme nous travaillons de plus en plus vieux,
les risques d'avoir une maladie grave pendant notre carrière
ne cessent d'augmenter.
Et avec les technologies nous permettant de travailler quand et d'où l'on veut,
la question n'est plus de savoir
si oui ou non, vous pouvez effectuer votre travail
dans les locaux de l'entreprise.
Ce n'est pas non plus
autoriser une pause plus longue ou fournir une chaise plus confortable,
même si ça reste appréciable.
Au minimum,
il faudrait pouvoir appliquer ces mesures d'assouplissement
à d'autres cas de figures
comme pour les personnes avec des responsabilités familiales.
Mais comment pourraient-elles avoir ne serait-ce qu'une discussion
sur ce qu'elles attendent en terme d'ajustements
si la première réaction de leur employeur est de leur dire :
« Oh non, ne revenez pas travailler jusqu'à ce que vous alliez mieux. »
Et là, j'ai eu une idée.
Il devrait être obligatoire pour un patron
d'avoir cette conversation avec ses employés.
Et les leçons de personnes comme moi
qui ont travaillé en étant malade et en ont tiré avantage
devraient être plus largement partagées.
J'ai réfléchi à comment conduire ces entretiens
et là mon incroyable collègue, Camilla Gunn,
a créé un guide « Travailler avec un cancer ».
Ce guide donne des conseils aux patients atteints,
à leurs employeurs, à leurs collègues et à leurs soignants,
sur comment parler du cancer et des aides professionnelles possibles.
Camilla et moi avons contacté d'autres structures
pour présenter ce livret
et expliquer comment il pourrait aider
à dialoguer sur un sujet qui peut être délicat.
Et je suis ravie d'annoncer que le livret est de plus en plus utilisé.
Donc, quelle devrait être la réponse d'un employeur
face à un salarié qui lui annonce sa maladie
et qui ignore l'impact que cela aura sur son travail ?
Cela devrait être ceci :
« Dans la mesure où vous en êtes capable et en avez envie,
nous serons ravis de trouver un arrangement
vous permettant de continuer à travailler. »
Nous devons encourager les personnes atteintes de maladies graves
à rester dans le milieu professionnel
plutôt que les mettre à l'écart.
Je vous ai raconté mon histoire pour que vous sachiez les bienfaits
que travailler m'a apportés
et changer votre opinion
si vous pensez que quelqu'un sous traitement
n'est rien autre que fatigué, fragile et ne fait que vomir.
Alors oui, c'est vrai parfois,
et même souvent,
mais j'avais la volonté de travailler
autant que je l'avais toujours fait.
Et j'ai pu le faire car on m'a donné le choix.
Mais plus encore, je vous en parle
car, s'il semble évident de laisser le choix,
travailler n'est en général pas encouragé, ni même proposé.
Pourtant cela devrait.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)